have you ever wondered how Attack on
Titan might have changed if Aaron's
mother was never eaten by a Titan in
this video we're gonna have a discussion
about the three different ways that I
think it might have gone because Carla's
death had a major impact on this series
especially when it comes to Aaron's
mentality and giving him the fuel he
needed to do the rumbling and a bunch of
other things if she hadn't died then
it's obvious his life would have gone in
a completely different direction and
yeah like I said there are three
realistic ways that I see it going and
so yeah we're just gonna be going
through them one by one in the comments
you can let me know which one you think
is most realistic alright so the first
question we need to ask ourselves is if
Aaron's mother is gonna survive how
exactly would it happen and when I was
thinking about this idea I realized that
there was an opportunity for harness to
save her life in episode 1 there was a
moment when harness showed up and
basically promised to save everyone and
he ran towards the smiling Titan almost
like he was gonna do something and then
in the end as we know he kind of like
just turned around grabbed the kids and
ran away way now if we imagine that
somewhere in the attack on Titan
Multiverse there's a reality where he
you know gathers up the courage and just
goes in slashes the spawning Titan and
by him doing this first of all it will
have big ramifications down the road
because if dinosaurs isn't alive then
her and Aaron will never have that
moment where he activates the founder
but even if we just put that to the side
for a second the main benefit in this
moment in time is that they'd be able to
free call from the rubble you know
they'd have enough time and then they
take her to the boats that we're heading
to wool Rose after that they join the
other refugees who are heading in the
same direction and at the same time
Grisha would have killed the royal
family and he'd be heading back to meet
them so we get this same moment in the
anime only this time around you know
Carla is alive and things would have to
play out a bit differently we have to
remember that possibly one of the
biggest questions of the anime is why
Grisha still gave Aaron his Titan even
though he saw the future and didn't want
Aaron to do the rumbling personally my
opinion on this is that the the reason
he still did it was that when he found
out Carla died all he cared about was
the fact that his wife was dead at the
hands of Mali and he said to Aaron like
you can get revenge for us that you can
get revenge for your mother her death
played a large part in the reason why
Grisha gave Aaron his Titan in that
moment and so I think that if he came
back and his family was still alive
would Grisha really take out into the
woods and give him a Titan shortening
his lifespan to 13 years and all the
things that come with it we also have to
factor in the fact that Grisha had been
on the island for 13 years and
throughout that whole time he'd always
prioritized his family over the mission
he cared about them more than he cared
about being an Alden restorationist so
would Grisha really take out into the
woods and give him a Titan it is a
little bit difficult to imagine that and
so for this first prediction I'm saying
that there is a timeline in which Grisha
prioritizes his family and he chooses
not to give Aaron the founding Titan in
this timeline I think he'd literally
just spend the room remaining days or
weeks that he has left with his family
and then eventually when he dies he kind
of just leaves it to fate like he's
leaving the whole future of the island
purely down to chance and I guess you
could say that's not a smart thing to do
and it's definitely not but if Carl is
alive and Aaron's alive and mikas is
alive and they've survived this attack
Grisha giving Aaron this time is
inevitably gonna tear the family apart
especially because he'd have to
disappear out of nowhere and he wouldn't
really be able to say goodbye to anyone
him disappearing Aaron getting a Titan
all those things it would just be so
much more complicated if Carla was
around and uh I think if she's alive
honestly I can see a reality where he
just doesn't do it and he dies of what
looks like natural causes but it's
really the curse of yamir all that being
said we do need to explore the second
option here which is that Grisha does
follow the same behavior that he did in
the anime and he gives Aaron the key
passes down his Titan and leaves without
really telling anyone you know what's
going on in a timeline like this things
would progress is mostly the same up
until the point where Aaron becomes old
enough to join the military before the
war was broken down Carla was adamant
she was like a hundred percent certain
that she would never let Aaron join the
scouts because you know like everyone
else she saw that whenever the Scouts
came back home they were always defeated
people were always dead and she didn't
want that for him she didn't want him to
get eaten now that was before the walls
were broken down so after the wars are
broken after seeing the Titans first
hand naturally witnessing how they eat
people alive I think there'd be a zero
percent chance that she'd ever allow him
to join it would be even less than when
the series began and so I genuinely
think that she wouldn't allow him to
join the military now you might say that
Aaron would just ignore her and join the
scouts regardless and while there is a
possibility we can't ignore the fact
that the leader of the cadets is Keith
shardis Keith is someone who's had a
crush on Carla for over a decade and you
know even in the main series when Carla
was dead Keith tried to sabotage Aaron
from joining the cadets for his own
safety like he wanted to protect Aaron
to protect Carla's memory so if we
imagine for a second that she's alive
and she actually has a word with him and
speaks to him about this I think Keith
would be even more aggressive in his
tactics to stop Aaron from joining this
could range from sabotaging his
equipment to making his life hell he
could just do all sorts of things to
make Aaron's life as difficult as
possible and again you could say oh well
Aaron would persevere he would you know
keep going but Keith has all the power
in the situation he could do I mean I'm
sure there's so many more things he
could have done that we didn't see that
could have affected Aaron's experience
in the cadets for argument's sake let's
just say he tampers with the equipment
and this time around he doesn't change
his mind and he allows Aaron to fail the
test meaning he never fully joins the
Cadance as a result Aaron would be sent
back home and likely Mikasa would go
along with him which by itself is a huge
blow to humanity because they lose their
second strongest Soldier then when the
battle in trust comes around I mean you
don't have Mikasa you don't have Aaron
cutting into a Titan so that in itself
creates a few problems I mean number one
the Titan that was charging towards
these people in this scene no one would
have stopped it in that case and all
these people including Louise they all
would have died the second thing is that
without Aaron turning into a Titan it
means that Reiner Annie and Berta would
have gone even further than they did
remember their original plan was for
Berthold to kick in the gate and they
were gonna see if the founding Titan
would reveal itself and if it didn't
they'd cause even more Carnage as Reiner
was going to knock in the inner gate of
wool Rose and Titans and people just go
flooding through this would create a
humanitarian crisis in which the entire
population of parodies Island would be
condensed into wool Cena which as we all
know is the smallest wall out of the
three with the amount of people there
are compared to the amount of food
inside wall Cena is just impossible like
there would have been a full-on civil
war between the people the Army and the
Royals it just there's no way that it
would have ended nicely it would have
definitely been a full out all-scale
Civil War caused by Rhino assuming that
Aaron doesn't turn into a Titan during
the Civil War I think the most likely
outcome is that the Warriors head back
to Mali and based on everything they've
learned you know from their perspective
they thought the king would appear and
defend the country from an attack from
outside Invaders but the fact remains
that you know on the occasions where
they've attacked no one showed up to
defend the island so you know if I was
them I would just assume that the king
for some reason isn't able to use his
power now the way Molly chooses to
respond to that information that's
probably the most unpredictable part
because you know in theory they could
then take that information and then go
and Blitz the island and just kill
everyone or they'd maybe say that
they're putting the plan on hold for a
while until they can work out whether
the king does or doesn't have the
founding Titan in this scenario it would
purely be down to someone like mcgath or
the general to work out whether it's
worth invading parodies for a second
time or if they're just gonna leave it
and focus their attention somewhere else
finally the third alternate reality by
Carlos advise this one is my personal
favorite and it's the one where Grisha
passes on his Titan to Aaron but in this
case he actually tells Aaron and he
tells Gala the truth about his backstory
in episode 1 we got the hint that Grisha
was finally getting ready to tell Aaron
the truth about his past but in the end
for some reason he didn't say anything
and he preferred for Aaron to you know
take the key and go and find out the
information for himself however with
Carla being alive it creates the
possibility that he might actually just
tell them everything and the reason I
say that is because if he doesn't say
anything and he just disappears he knows
that's going to hurt his wife a lot you
know like if he just gives the time to
Aaron doesn't say anything he's going to
be a missing person and Carl is going to
have no idea what happened to him so I
think as a husband this would be the
most reasonable thing he could do if he
was going to give Aaron the founding
Titan additionally if Carla finds out
the truth about the outside world and
all the people who want to kill them it
might cause a little bit of a change in
her mindset in my opinion I think number
one she wouldn't one Grisha to pass his
Titan down to anyone because obviously
that means her husband is about to get
eaten but if he's insistent on doing it
then I think she suggests someone like
Keith should be the next founder Keith
is someone that she's known for a long
time and let's face it she'd rather that
he dies from the curse of Emir rather
than her 10 year old son now if
Christian was to keep insisting that it
had to be Aaron and let's just assume
that he does go ahead and gives his son
the founding Titan that would lead to a
whole new scenario because if we can
imagine this for a second if Aaron knew
from the very beginning that anyone he
meets could be a Titan from Mali and he
knew about the outside world from the
start that creates an entirely different
series it would be a series in which he
knows he can't trust anyone so I mean
number one I'd imagine he'd make a lot
less friends and number two he'd be more
skeptical of everyone he meets in the
main anime I say that Aaron was quite a
trusting person like whenever Annie or
Ryan or Roberto whenever they were
spoken about is potentially being traded
he was always the one to say no guys it
can't be them whereas everyone else was
a bit more like you know like it might
be them it might be so I think in this
new scenario Aaron would be a lot more
skeptical he'd be a lot more willing to
believe that people are working for the
enemy when it comes to the attack on
trust this time when the Colossal Titan
appears Aaron would immediately know
that this is someone he potentially
knows he'd know that it's a person and
so after the Colossal disappears Aaron
would likely chase after Bertolt whether
he's successful or not is a different
question because if I remember correctly
I think bertol did rank ahead of Aaron
in the cadet rankings which is to be
expected because they already had
military training before they even
joined the cadets
um so yeah I think bursle would be
skillful enough to get away eventually
the chaos in trust would get to the
point where Aaron has to decide whether
he's willing to reveal his Titan and you
know expose himself in order to save the
people who were in the city ultimately I
do think things would get bad enough him
to do this because if he doesn't turn
into a Titan then who's gonna plug the
hole in the wall like someone still
needs to do that and of course that
would lead to a similar series of events
as in the main Series in which Reiner
Annie and bertol paused their attack
because they finally found a Titan
shifter from the island following that
Aaron would get arrested and put on
trial just like you'd expect only this
time around the military would take
Carla hostage as well we have to
remember that the people of the island
don't know anything about Titan Shifters
so from their perspective if Aaron could
turn into a Titan then there's a good
possibility in their minds that Carla
can turn into one as well for that
reason Carla would be locked in an
underground cell or she'd be put on
trial with Aaron at the same time and
together they'd both be grilled by the
military about their knowledge of Titans
and their motivations of course they
wouldn't just say everything that Grisha
told them because that can cause a whole
bunch of problems in itself but what I
would think is that Aaron would suggest
that they go to shiganshana where they
can find proof about the Titans in
grisha's basement assuming that Evan
would want to go along with this from
this point onwards I think things would
play out mostly the same with the big
difference coming in season 2 with the
diner Fritz moment as we've established
in this alternate timeline Dino Fritz
was killed in shiganshana by Hardis so
when we come around to the season 2
finale Aaron is basically there
was a moment in the finale where Ryan
just began chucking Titans at everyone
and of course Aaron was injured so he
couldn't transform if it wasn't for him
luckily Awakening his powers in this
moment I think we can all agree everyone
would have died Mikasa was injured so
she wasn't in good shape Irvin had lost
an arm almond and John they were knocked
off their horse I mean same for Aaron as
well like he was not of his horse he
couldn't transform so everyone was
screwed like they weren't in a good
situation the reason I like this though
is because a few years ago I remember
seeing a quote from isayama where he
said that he planned to end Attack on
Titan like the movie The Mist and
although I haven't seen that movie the
ending is super iconic because it's
basically where the main character to he
had to kill everyone he loves because
there wasn't any way to escape the
monsters an ending like that is
something that isayama originally
planned to do and I think in this
ultimate timeline this is the scenario
where that missed ending would happen
literally all of Aaron's closest friends
would be killed and eaten by Titans
right in front of him as he'd be unable
to transform and with no Diner Fritz he
wouldn't be able to activate the
coordinate the timeline could then end
with Aaron himself being eaten and once
that's done whoever ate Aaron would just
be a confused random person and Ryan
reversa would be able to take them and
bring them back to Mali what follows
this would be Mali invading parodies and
stealing their natural resources while
subjugating and wiping out the local
population honestly if this had happened
it would have been the saddest possible
ending of Attack on Titan and I guess
it's one of the many reasons why Carla
had to die that is just my opinion
though so let me know in the comments
down below what you think and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you want to see more videos like this
I'd appreciate it if you dropped a like
as well as it does help out the channel
and until the next one peace out